vielen dank mein thema ist das
selbstbestimmungsrecht das gerade im
bundestag forciert wird von der
bundesregierung es geht im wesentlichen
darum dass die begriffe von mann und
frau die geschlechter die wir kennen der
aufgerufen werden sollen ganz klar
aufgehoben sie sollen künftig nicht mehr
existent sein das heißt jeder kann sich
künftig der erklärung beim standesamt
das wird ungefähr 20 euro kosten die
neue personalausweis zum mann oder zur
frau macht das bedeutet ich kann mich
dann per erklärung zur frau erklären
frauchen kann sagen ich möchte gern mal
ein mann sein oder diverse und das
schöne an der ganzen sache ist dass es
dann nach kurzer zeit nämlich nach einem
jahr wieder möglich ist zu wechseln wenn
es ihnen nicht gefällt ändern sie wieder
ihr geschlecht natürlich muss man sagen
es gibt eine notwendigkeit im
transsexuellen menschen und non binären
menschen zu helfen allerdings darf man
natürlich nicht übersehen dass die nur
ein nicht nur dass die ein prozent der
bevölkerung ausmachen dieses gesetz er
führt jetzt dazu dass 99 prozent der
bürger die mit ihrer geschlechterrolle
keine nennenswerten probleme haben auch
das recht bekommen ihr geschlecht
komplett einfach per erklärung zu ändern
von heute auf morgen und das zum
beispiel eltern das recht bekommen für
einen neugeborenen zu bestimmen dass der
jonas der einen penis hat und die sophie
die eine vagina künftig die rollen
tauschen und der junge ein mädchen ist
und das mädchen ein junge das ist der
plan des gesetzgebers der schutz der
transsexuellen und non binären menschen
ist völlig richtig und wichtig das ist
überhaupt steht außer frage das ist ja
auch vom bundesverfassungsgericht zuvor
gegeben allerdings ist es so dass
natürlich hier die frage gestellt was
ist denn mit den anderen 99 prozent was
machen denn die mit diesem gesetz und
mit hier öffnen sich aus meiner
bewertung wenn jeder praktisch machen
kann was er will mit dem geschlecht
missbrauchsmöglichkeiten ich rede jetzt
also nicht von den unmittelbar
betroffenen den 1 prozent die wirklich
einen leidensdruck haben sondern von den
99 prozent die das gesetz nutzen können
und ich nenne diese leute die das nutzen
werden trittbrettfahrer das sind die
trittbrettfahrer die künftig sagen oh es
kostet ja nichts sein geschlecht zu
ändern dann mache ich das mal die
spaßvögel sind vielleicht die harmlosen
was ist aber mit den spaßvögeln die dann
tatsächlich meinen sie können zum
beispiel in ruhe schutzräume für frauen
eintreten im wahrsten sinn des wortes
und dort sicher zeigen das ist dann nach
dem gesetz völlig möglich schutzräume
sind ein beispiel frauenquoten sind mit
dem neuen es hätte es gab auch schon
beinahe fehler beispielsweise für die
schutzwand amerikanischen werbung messen
flüchtig sind ja auch schon wirklich
gefährliche dinge passiert ich würde
gerne einmal damit mich wir fünf die
alle glauben natürlich tropfen sind
darüber leben einmal von sabit blank der
letzte woche hier bei 48 zu gast einen
ganz kurzen ausschnitt zeigen
also ihr lösungsvorschlag wäre es später
zu machen erst mit 18 vielleicht oder
was ihr vorschlag also auf jeden fall
erst mit 18 das auf jeden fall und dass
es halt nicht zu verfrühten operationen
und so weiter kommt also ich hatte zum
beispiel im krankenhaus nebenwert einen
18-jährigen der hat direkt mastektomie
hysterektomie your back to me zusammen
gemacht als ob die gebärmutter und
eierstöcke entfernung bei dem sein arzt
ihm gesagt hat dass er sonst krebs
bekommen würde und das war halt keine
weitere irgendwie erklärungen halt
darüber also klagen war bewusst dass er
dann keine kinder kriegen kann aber
krebs ist halt irgendwie da eine gefahr
womöglich in zehn jahren aber es ist ja
nicht glauben die politik befördert das
mit dem selbstbestimmung gesetz derzeit
auf jeden fall ja frau sammelt blank man
noch schockieren das anzusehen hat
nämlich sich die brüste abnehmen lassen
und hormone genommen und bereit ist
jetzt und tritt sehr mutig wie ich finde
jetzt auch auf und darüber aufzuklären
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass durch
das selbstbestimmungsrecht
vertreten wo es menschen später bereuen
das ist ganz aus meiner sicht ganz
eindeutig der fall durch diese
weitgehenden möglichkeiten die jetzt
auch eltern eingeräumt werden ich kann
es ernsthaft nicht nachvollziehen wenn
man davon ausgeht dass die unabhängige
entwicklung eines kindes ja ein gut als
solches ist das zum beispiel eltern dann
ab dem ersten lebensmonat das recht
gegeben wird zu sagen wo unser kind hat
eine rosa war russell
am bett fixiert also muss es ein mädchen
sein obwohl ein junge ist das heißt also
hier wird die ungestörte sexuelle
entwicklung auch von kindern extrem
gefährdet indem man eben hier so einen
weitgehenden spielraum gibt ohne dass
man überhaupt dann noch danach fragt
gibt es hier überhaupt sozusagen einen
klinischen grund ja also ein
leidensdruck den wie gesagt lediglich
ein prozent der betroffenen überhaupt
verspürte der der bürger verspüren eine
bedenkenswerte sehr wie hoch schätzen
sie die gefahr ein naja ich kann da
jetzt schlechte zahlen operieren das ist
jetzt ja wirklich eine spekulation
vielleicht ist es auch viel weniger
vielleicht der leidensdruck höflich sehr
geringer das weiß ich nicht aber ein
entscheidender punkt ist ja hier in
einem einspieler gemacht worden ist
worden dass man offenbar schon und da
verstehe ich die fdp überhaupt nicht das
ist also liberalität für durchgeknallte
dass man als 14-jähriger oder ab 14
jahren das schon machen sollen darf also
man ist noch gar nicht entwickelt man
ist noch in der pubertät man ist nicht
strafmündig ist aber soll aber bereits
mündlich sein sein sein geschlecht zu
wechseln und vielleicht sogar auf
operabel weiß also ich sage ja sie muss
war gegen den willen der eltern und das
finde ich das geht nicht also man kann
ich sagen mit 14 bis zum strafe und ich
darf nicht genug alkohol trinken darf
kein auto fahren keine verträge
abschließen aber dachte ich oh bohren
lassen bis die schwarte kracht und die
eltern müssen uns nicht mal zustimmen
das finde ich nicht das ist dann froh
dass es also meines wissens ist das noch
in der schwebe lässt als aktuelle
angebote auch gern da stand das bis 18
zustimmen müssen müssen sie es kann aber
auch eine rechtliche klärung soll sind
die kinder ein gericht beispielsweise
geben wenn sich eltern will und kindes
willen also die bauarbeiten seien aus
dem elternhaus aus brechen indem sie
ihre kinder auf eine aufwändige
schlechte tradition sozusagen verklagen
das ist der gesetzentwurf trägt und
linke denn das neue
selbstbestimmungsrecht mit herbert ihn
getragen dass mit und ich glaube man
muss
da differenzieren also es geht da in
diesem fall ging es um eine
geschlechtsanpassung tradition
hier geht es erstmal um
personenstandsrecht
kurz kommen einfach immer davor gewarnt
stehen weil das transsexuellengesetz was
wir jetzt damit abgeschafft wird was ist
diskriminierend war da haben sie recht
da hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
einige urteile immer getroffen
beispielsweise die frage der schwanken
zwangssterilisation
das macht niemand freiwillig das wird
einfach auch nicht mehr gemacht das ist
abgeschafft worden dann hat das damals
vorgesehen man musste sich vom
ehepartner im trend von seiner frau von
seinem man beispielsweise im trend das
ist abgeschafft worden macht auch
heutzutage niemand genau so wie damit
mit den urteilen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts insgesamt die
die geschlechtsumwandlung zurückgegangen
haben sind und wir wissen aus anderen
ländern beispielsweise dänemark hat 2014
ein selbstbestimmungsrecht eingeführt
was dem deutschen vergleichbar ist und
was das fortschrittlichste
aber das nehme ich noch eine beobachtung
da anführen da war es wirklich so wie
sie es auch richtig gesagt hat es
betrifft die 99 prozent nicht
dass hier
erwarten wenn frau blanca von gerade
sagen es macht die tür der welt auf
selbstverständlich aber es gibt diese
beobachtung beim
selbstbestimmungsrecht dass da eben das
gegenteil ist weil es teilweise den
druck nimmt sozusagen das heißt ich nahm
mir den eintrag nehmen ich fühle mich
als frau ich muss aber nicht unbedingt
eine geschlechtsumwandlung machen und
die problematik hat sie ja da sehr gut
und sehr eindrücklich in ihrer sendung
geschildert schon so gerade diese
eigentlich vor diesem sinn sagt es macht
die tür auf sie können es nicht aber die
besagt aber die narbe die die
beobachtungen gemacht haben sagte ist
die beobachtung die wir gemacht haben
sowohl mit dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts und den
auswirkungen
geschlechtsumwandlung sind dadurch
zurück am gegangen aber
sie
einzuladen also stehen menschen die
wissen das ist nicht mein haupt der ja
dem feld ich beschäftige mich vor allem
mit energie und klimapolitik aber ich
finde es sehr
interessanter
unterschiedliche meinungen zu hören und
positionen zu hören ich finde das auch
total wichtig finde es auch gut dass sie
eingeladen haben und die diskussion ich
bin nur sagen ist in zwei
unterschiedlichen
ebenen ist so ist die ebene der
geschlechtsanpassung wo sie japanische
erschüttert hat und das
selbstbestimmungsrecht die erfahrungen
aus dänemark und diese erfahrung mit dem
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil zeigen
dass es hier eben da nicht zusammen ja
es geht juristisch aber nicht so sehr um
die betroffenen die betroffenen haben ja
das reservierte er wird dafür die
betroffenen von einer geschlechts
identitätsstörung die haben natürlich
das recht dass ihm geholfen wird und da
ist es richtig dass das
transsexuellengesetz zum beispiel
abgeschafft werden muss und durch eine
andere lösung abgelöst werden muss wovon
ich rede sind die 99 prozent der bürger
die überhaupt kein problem mit ihrer
geschlechtsidentität haben die sich
künftig aber nach belieben einmal im
jahr von mann zu frau machen können wir
uns von frau zu mann mit allen rechten
mit glauben sie denn dass uns wirklich
dann auch gemacht
vorhin gesprochen wir brauchen doch nur
in einem fall des missbrauchs dass es
gemacht wird dass männer in schutzräume
eindringen dass männer juristisch sich
einen klaren jetzt tauchen krankenhaus
stationen für frauen und ähnliches das
sind ganz praktische dinge was passiert
jetzt schon aber sie diesen missbrauch
jetzt dass sich jemand überlegt als die
99 prozent von denen sie angesprochen
haben dass man sein geschlecht ändert
diese missbrauchten sehe ich nicht so
als das problem bei dieser geschichte
sind vor allem die teenager die noch
nicht wissen in welche richtung geht es
und wenn sie dann die möglichkeit haben
zwischen einem geschlecht usw zu
unterscheiden und dann in der diskussion
zu hause mit den eltern sind und das ist
glaube ich ein kleiner in einer phase wo
man sozusagen sich selber sucht dass man
jetzt vielleicht die möglichkeit hat es
gibt ja auch schon pubertäts blog harfe
kinder bei totalen amerikas wir die
situation dass es dass die kliniken
jetzt boom diese geschlechtsumwandlung
schon für teenager machen und das finde
ich das ist die gefährliche entwicklung
das ist nicht das jetzt jemand wie ich
jetzt plötzlich sagen okay nächstes jahr
überlege ich mir ob ich eine frau bin um
irgendeinen vorteil der sendung
angekommen also gibt es noch 40
frauen und alle meinen jetzt mal darüber
nachdenken in ruhe und wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend und morgen
abend werden wieder zurück weil viele
nach acht schüssen abend noch